I have noticed since I've been in
America the value of people around me
being excitable British are we are
genetically predisposed to be kind of
Dow personality is very similar to the
weather it's sort of gray and
everything's a bit we're very great with
the satire and the sarcasm and The
Cutting remarks and stuff but my
disposition doesn't need any more of
that and what I realized one of the
reasons that I've flourished since I've
been in America is I've been around
people who believe that things are going
to be better than they are right now
they continually presume progress is
baked in it it's factored in all the
time that things are going to get better
of course stuff's going to grow oh dude
it's going to be fine this catastrophe
you're going to get over it and
everything that may be America overall
I'm not sure that may just be my
particular cohort of particular people
in this particular City that I'm living
in but what it's done is it's raised my
ambient mood an awful lot